the blue screen of death or BSOD is
always an unwelcome sight fortunately
however modern computers can easily
recover from this and automatically
repair themselves but for those of you
guys who repeatedly experienced a blue
screen of death what are some probable
causes and solutions and first of all
what even is the blue screen of death
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies yesterday we
covered the blue light that is emitted
from your devices and busts admit that
it is actually bad for your eyes today
we're taking a look at a completely a
blue screen with an error message blue
screens of death are full screen errors
which usually displayed after series
system crashes if you have Windows 7 or
lower these actually look fatal if you
have Windows 8 or 10 however it's much
more user-friendly a BSOD or blue screen
of death
is actually just a popularized name for
a stop message or stop error blue
screens of death usually freeze a
computer and require a reboot in an
effort to prevent any further damage
from occurring when a blue screen of
death occurs when this automatically
creates a may dump file and save it to
your disk if you take a look at these
files then you may be able to identify
the cause of the blue screen of death
blue screens of death are typically
caused by the system Hardware
temperature timing resources quick
registries or viruses here are the four
most common error codes what they mean
and what you can do to prevent them in
the future
the first error message is RQL not less
or equal this generally means that there
may be some improperly installed drivers
for something you bought recently for
example if you recently got some your
headphones keyboards or pretty much any
peripherals then they probably had some
drivers going along with them
if you don't remember installing any
drivers recently then the next time that
the blue screen of death happens you can
actually look at the bottom the blue
screen of death and identify what it is
for instance if it says NV 4 underscore
D is P DLL then this represent a video
card error if you recently made a GPU
switch then this issue can easily be
solved but making sure that you have
incorrect drivers and are up to date
the next issue that a bus error is one
of the easiest ones to diagnose but it
is almost always related to the RAM
sticks if you recently got these RAM
sticks but make sure that they are
compatible with your motherboard and
plug into write slots
furthermore if you're overclocking or
gene and timings then it may be best to
reset it to default at least for now
base your timings may be too aggressive
unfortunately if none of these issues
apply to you then it may just be due to
back RAM sticks NTFS file system or fat
file system if you get this error
message and make sure to backup the most
important files from your main OS Drive
as quickly as possible because your SSD
or hard drive may be honest laughs like
it may be as simple as a loose SATA
cable so make sure to check that first
if that's securely connected you
probably want to run check disk you can
easily do this by opening up command
prompt and type in chkdsk /f Forbes last
art and finally if you see the error
message unexpected kernel mode trap then
it may be due to a couple of issues is
the most common for CPU overclockers but
can also appear due to bad RAM or krupka
bios if you recently increased a
frequency of your CPU then this issue
can easily be solid but just taking it
back a little bit if that is not the
problem then to further isolate the
issue then run mem test 86 on RAM sticks
to check if that is the issue and try
updating your bios finally while this is
very uncommon if none of those worked
then it may just mean a back to you as a
bonus here's some quick overviews of
some other error messages page fault and
non page area is usually caused by
faulty hardware such as RAM in the
excess of a boot drive it's usually
caused by a boot sector virus or
improper IDE controller drives beat your
driver I and IDE it's usually caused by
the wrong drivers installed for video
card bad pool color is usually caused by
incompatible hardware drivers and is
common when updating Windows 10 list
scrub is usually caused by a faulty RAM
and finally machine check exception is
usually caused by an issue with the CPU
if you ever run into a BSOD then don't
panic most of BS LDS are caused by
solved related issues and Lauren
computers can fix them automatically
however if you repeatedly face be Saudis
here's a quick guide for action use
System Restore scan for malware and tell
updated drivers boot into safe mode or
finally reinstall windows if none of
these work and I hate to say it but it
may just be a hardware issue but let's
hope it's not so is there something
crucial that I missed about psoas major
comment that down below also if you guys
fans forget to be helpful
then make sure drop a like and consider
subscribing if you like to see more
videos just like this one every single
day but till then I'm Hari and I'll see
you guys on the next one
[Music]